the family early warning system started
in 1985 and it was started as a
consequence of the massive loss of life
over a million people due to drought
related famine in the Sahel and Ethiopia
and other areas of East Africa the idea
was to make sure that nothing like that
would ever happen again
the famine early warning system Network
also known as fews net helps the US
Agency for International Development
plan its food aid and relief efforts
it combines satellite and on-the-ground
data to predict droughts months in
advance there was not a lot of work that
really looked in a kind of rigorous way
at how to combine those two sources of
information in the best way and so
that's been you know one of the things
that that I've specialized in there have
been a number of initiatives which allow
for the increase in the number of rain
gauges that are available the satellites
data really hinges on the the rain gauge
data for its
calibration we now have a product called
the climate hazards group infrared
precipitation with stations or chirps
which combines observations from
satellites and gauges to produce what's
probably the best rainfall product for
drought early warning chirps was
deployed in early 2015 just in time to
monitor worsening conditions of drought
in Ethiopia troops dataset was in many
ways kind of designed from the get-go to
deal with rainfall in Ethiopia because
it's a really challenging place to try
to track rainfall variations it's
incredibly mountainous and those
mountains have a huge impact on the
rainfall where you can go from really
wet Highlands to super hot dry lowlands
and you know maybe 50 kilometers over
the years fuse that has improved its
ability to predict climate patterns like
the El Nino Southern Oscillation or sea
surface temperature shift every few
years in the equatorial Pacific Ocean
the shifts lead to weather changes all
over the world even as far away as
Africa
which was focus to be one of the
strongest El Ninos on record it's all in
Africa the Alina Southern Oscillation
tends to have that correlation between
El Nino and below normal rainfall the
drought in Ethiopia in 2015 was very
similar to the drought in 1984 you know
that helped kill a million people the
outcome of the 2015 drought was very
different than 1984 early warnings led
to increased food aid helping the nation
avoid many deaths but human-induced
global warming will worsen droughts and
storms which means that the specter of
drought and famine isn't going away
you have in mind that in the background
the odds have been tilted in one
direction or another because of climate
change then that helps increase
confidence in the outlets that are
produced we should be expecting you know
more of these extreme events these
really strong El Nino and La Nina events
in the last five years at least we've
had those sequence of droughts which
have had as increasingly negative impact
on households simply because of the
reduction in the coping capacity if this
happens again and were in this situation
where we're grappling with a kind of
post covin reality I'm worried about in
the future if we have reduced economic
capacity that a super kind of El Nino
like happens again could have really
dire consequences our scope now is to
always be able to work globally and be
able to respond wherever we're going to
be needed in the future